Speaker 1: All right. So these right
wing stories about people crying,
they've become so ridiculous that they're
essentially parodies of themselves.
I'm not really going to show you one of
those here. From Republican Senator Ted Cruz,
although it certainly reminded me of it. But
this actually is one of these stories about
people coming up to me. The prototypical one that
Trump tells as, oh, you know, we're the people
that arrested last week. He said the people that
arrested me were crying when they arrested me.
The the sort of subtext of this particular
story from Ted Cruz is that whenever he lands
at different airports, police just flock to him,
police flock to him, and they just all support him
so much. And this is again, it's dubious. It's
always dubious when Ted Cruz in this clip, he's
going to say it's a dozen dozen police officers
or whatever. It's probably happened at some point
that a police officer came up to Ted Cruz and
gave him a patch or whatever Cruz says here. But
there's a very significant political utility to
these particular types of stories. So listen to
this one and then we're going to talk about it.
Speaker 2: The most striking place to fly into a
Chicago island. It's Chicago O'Hare Airport.
I am with some regularity, met by ten, 12,
15 uniformed police officers who come. They shake
my hand, they give me patches. I've got my office
patches of the Chicago P.D. that are displayed in
my office because those cops are so under assault.
Speaker 1: But were they crying when they met
you, sir? Okay. So it's what is the point of
these stories at this point in time? The point is
that it would be extremely dangerous and damaging
to Republicans for it to become known that there
is plenty of military and law enforcement that
supports Democrats. And in fact, when you look
at the 2020 presidential election, one of the
interesting things about, yes, the military leans
right. There is no question about that. But one
of the interesting things about the military vote
in 2020 is that it was one of the highest levels
of support for the Democratic candidate that
Joe Biden received from members of the military
than had been seen by Democrats for a very long
time. I don't remember the exact numbers. They
don't really matter. But the point is, compared to
past elections, it was a higher level of support.
And this is all because Republicans want and to
some degree have obtained a monopoly on certain
elements of political discourse, law and order,
or, as Trump once called it, law and order,
auto insurance, very, very important issue, but
something else altogether. Republicans use this
law and order messaging. We are for law and order
when it comes to immigration, when it comes to
street crime, when it comes to demonstrations,
when it comes to all of these different things.
And they portray themselves as the arbiters of law
and order. And so they do that to appeal to voters
who prioritize safety and who prioritize security.
Now understand that it's total B.S. It's complete
and total utter B.S. The reality is law and order
means we want our political enemies targeted,
but we don't want to be targeted when we do the
same things. Law and order means we support the
police, except when it's the D.C. Capitol Police
trying to beat off rioters on January 6th of 2021,
or we law and order. Except when it's not law and
order, no one is above the law except when it's
Trump. And then why isn't he above the law? He
should be above the law. That's the messaging. And
if it became known that they aren't actually the
party of law and order, it would be very damaging.
Nationalism and patriotism. Another element of
this supposedly. So remember, it's supposedly
pro-police narrative. The Republican Party often
translates or utilizes stated support for police
in the military as a point of national pride.
They must love the country more because they
support police and police support them. But that
doesn't really make any sense. Or the military,
again, and particularly when there's
a crisis or a conflict or a war,
as we saw during the Iraq war under George W
Bush's presidency, that can actually be pretty
useful. It taps into feelings of loyalty and
duty among many in the country. And then thirdly,
this narrative about how much police love Ted
Cruz. It's to draw a distinction with Democrats.
You emphasize, you know, we have the support of
police and members of the military, and that's
because Democrats are weak or they're unpatriotic
or whatever. And if Democrats are seen as being
critical of law enforcement, then that contrast
is even even more. More useful. So it's another
one of these. They come up to me with tears in
my eyes. Stories from Cancun. Ted Cruz. But it is
part of a much larger political area of political
strategy that if Republicans were to lose and they
should lose it because it's all completely
fabricated, would be very damaging to them.